so I was the ultimate minimalist I
washed my face body hair and shave of
the barb Neutrogena you know very clean
rectangles yeah and I was a beauty buyer
for Barneys when it was a family-owned
and operated business so I had like
thousands of things available to me that
I couldn't use and I'd bring them home
we knew each other maybe for two years
at this point and you know eventually
and you started to see that something
more than just above Neutrogena soap
made a difference yes and and sometimes
when he would sort of that the the
various different items I would be able
than to try something as with my job
evaluate in the first place that might
in fact be appropriate for my particular
skin type I think what I learned is or
my evolution was that there is it
doesn't necessarily more expensive but
there are definitely differences in
quality and you use a better product you
have better results but i also found
from just a design perspective it was
broke out there there were so many steps
it was very intimidating and i'm a firm
believer of less is more not only in
architecture and design but also in your
whole lifestyle that you don't need to
do 150 different things just to get out
the door and the fact of the matter is
we live in New York and our customers
live in urban centers they don't have
time for ritualistic ten step programs
but which aren't even efficacious anyway
but most interestingly andrew is he's
quite oily and his skin is fairly a
resilient mine is dry in quite sensitive
I had suffer from several different
existing conditions and what we found
through the years was that in fact there
were only a few things that were really
effective for both of us and it wasn't a
complicated understanding of these you
know expansive ideas of skincare was
really a great cleanser great
moisturizer and when you started to then
look at Neutrogena as a company and you
start to look at three step clinic and
sort of these very simple ideas if you
can create sort of the best cleanser and
the best moisturizer you've really sort
of established the core of what you need
I mean you don't need a tertiary product
if you already have the best
yes so that's uh so those words of the
real voids that that we saw in the
marketplace and I and I think that we've
sort of hit Helmand mostly yeah and also
there was a void there were very few
unisex Browns you know most people so
there was an amazing opportunity to
literally add fifty percent to your
market by being unisex and the fashion
of matter is whether you're a man or
women or whatever your ethnicity is
we're all basically biologically the
same so this whole idea of marketing
that you're from here you're from there
and your mask with your feminine is you
know this is sort of it really came down
to the idea of how a modern couple could
shop for and use products together
somebody with oily resilient skin
somebody with dry sensitive skin and it
didn't matter what your sex was or your
your race or etc etc that you could
share these products and that they would
be really effective and really great and
even your skin type whether you're the
pendulum skews one way or the other most
people are somewhere in between and have
a combination of different skin
conditions on their face which can
change with hormones with age with
weather seasons so it's never it's
always a moving target so and we try to
address all those things in a way that
other companies haven't done
yeah I did as a matter of fact it
doesn't he look great he's like 80 years
old almost but not quite thank you very
much sometimes I feel like a tee but ya
know you do you do notice it and you you
feel better
I think that there's a lot of sort of
passion behind the brand in terms of how
it connects with the consumer that it's
real it's not just another corporation
creating a brand for the sake of
marketing we really try to do something
that was special and unique and fill a
void in the marketplace and to do
something from a family owned and
operated at approach something that was
local and interesting and specific to
our customer base and I think also what
makes the brand so strong is that we
really put so much energy into creating
really superior or great products and
and people when they experience
something efficacious they come back and
they tell other people so we're why
we're not advertising and having great
marketing campaigns we have this great
almost gorilla or word-of-mouth campaign
because people use everything and I love
it so much and we're also really true to
the brand we don't develop things
because the season is saying this is in
vogue now or this is in vogue tomorrow
we we develop products that we really
believe the market needs or that we
would actually use I mean most of the
products were developed around our own
lifestyles oh sorry I was going to say
the same everything else I same but we
in fact what you know in terms of
filling voids part of it was addressing
our own specific lifestyle in terms of
those particular Boyd's so most of the
products in the brand itself really
speaks to how we live our lives every
single day and those experiences from
Andrews design background and those
experiences from my beauty background
and how we could create something really
wonderful and unique and infill these
sort of marketplace avoids that that
made a difference in a way that we would
use them ourselves because we needed
them or we wanted them